[Música]
mi familia es propietaria de franquicias
de farmacias en otros signos cuando el
yen se ausente en algunas de ellas y no
esté en la escuela yo soy quien queda a
cargo y si si estoy capacitada llevo
cinco años haciéndolo
es mi hermano cuando de repente llega a
la mamá despertado todo el hogar sea si
la quieren llamar su hijo de siete años
tienen infección en la garganta pero
como no es la primera vez que se enferma
y quiere evitar pagar la consulta con el
doctor hace una búsqueda rápida en
internet y encuentra que la mochis y
lina con ácido clavulánico le puede
ayudar entonces me la pide y yo le digo
que necesita receta porque es un
antibiótico pero insiste en que se la dé
porque ella supuestamente ya los
adulantes y yo le pregunto cómo podría
darse la si ni siquiera sabemos si su
hijo es alérgico al medicamento y le
responde que no lo es él solo es
alérgico a la piscina
entonces le digo la medicina con ácido
clavulánico es son el lado de la cocina
les recomiendo pasa consulta para que le
receten el tratamiento correcto
desafortunadamente
no pasa una vez cada dos años sino que
sucede al menos tres veces en un día
si visualizaremos excitación en todo
méxico mínimo 156 mil personas por día
ponen en riesgo su vida a causa de la
discusión con esto no me refiero a que
deban saber que la amoxicilina es son
derivada de la consigna porque no se
supone que todos seamos farmacéuticos el
problema es que piensen que esta
regulación sólo está para molestar y no
por el bien de su propia salud
así una percepción piensen ok bueno nada
más no se lo vendas y ya no hay futuras
consecuencias pero adivinen que una de
las víctimas más graves de
desinformación son las vacunas y la
diferencia es que en administrar telas
no sólo te afecta a ti sino a tu familia
amigos ciudad estado país y al mundo
en este momento seguramente te estás
preguntando se supone que una chica de
preparatoria
me hable de salud pública no porque se
pasó un poco de farmacia y eres experta
de la salud a lo que yo te respondo que
tienes toda la razón si estuviera en tu
lugar
pensaría lo mismo pero la realidad es
que te hablaré de una perspectiva que
puedo asegurar no te hayas pensado y que
como jóvenes podríamos implementar para
combatir este problema
entonces si queremos llegar a una
solución el primer paso es identificar
las causas del problema como primer
punto se encuentran las creencias y
construcciones sociales
de 19 comenzó la vacunación contra la
viruela después de que el ternero
demostrara que podía administrar a un
niño administrándole una linfa de una
de la viruela vacuna con base en
los registros históricos del colegio de
médicos de filadelfia
este hallazgo fue muy novedoso para la
época por lo que rápidamente surgió
oposición
en cuanto al aspecto sanitario los papás
consideraban que el hecho de cortarla y
el del brazo de un niño e introducirle
la linfa de la ampolla de una persona
que ya había sido vacunada el anti
higiénico en lo religioso la cuestión
era que la vacuna no era algo cristiana
porque provenía de un animal y por tanto
era inmoral en cuanto a la política la
gente declaraba que las vacunas
arremetían contra su derecho a la
libertad debido a que obligaban a
administrarse las íes que a pesar de la
antigüedad de la situación este tipo de
creencias aún perduran en la sociedad
en segundo lugar se encuentran los
intereses entre grupos de poder
probablemente suene conocida la
controversia sobre la vacuna en el mar o
por sus siglas en inglés sarampión
paperas y lugar resulta que en 1998 el
doctor británico new wave lo publicó un
artículo en la revista médica de las
proponiendo que la vacuna no se aprobaba
correctamente
y que estaba directamente relacionada
con el autismo
en 2004 la misma revista declaró que no
hay que haber dividido el estudio porque
el consejo del médico general descubrió
que una junta legal le había pagado al
doctor para que investigara si había
pruebas que demostraran fallas en la
vacuna y sustentarán un litigio
solicitado por padres que aseguraban que
ésta les había producido reacciones
adversas a sus hijos
después de investigaciones en 2010 le
retiraron su licencia para ejercer la
medicina en gran bretaña y en 2011 el
british medical journal publicó informes
donde se prueba que wakefield había
realizado fraude por falsificar datos y
que las uñas del caso ya presentaban
síntomas de autismo desde antes
hasta el momento no hay evidencia
científica que demuestre una relación
entre las vacunas y el auto
una vez establecidos los puntos
anteriores el siguiente paso es analizar
el desarrollo que en este caso es la
propagación de la desinformación
en meses pasados y una de la pose de
netflix llamada pandemia este programa
presenta un caso muy interesante de un
movimiento anti vacunas en el estado de
oregón debido a un fuerte brote de
sarampión en el año de 2019
en américa no llego considerar
implementar una ley que obliga a los
padres a que vacunarán a sus hijos para
poder asistir a la escuela de forma que
se realizó una audiencia pública para
que la población presentara sus posturas
o la mamá se oponía debido a que cuando
tenía 17 años la vacuna del papiloma
humano le causó parálisis facial durante
tres meses
otra chica adolescente mencionó que a
causa de la vacuna triple viral no pudo
caminar ni hablar durante cuatro meses
otra mamá exponía que esta misma cuna le
produjo colitis microscópica a su hijo y
no tuvo una evacuación sólida hasta los
8 años
sin embargo la senadora de obregón
stinger hayward quien es médica familiar
certificada menciona específicamente que
la correlación no prueba la causalidad
si bien es cierto que se pueden
representar reacciones adversas es casi
nula la posibilidad de que situaciones
de gravedad se relacionen con las
vacunas de forma que el problema con
estos movimientos es que todos los casos
presentan como culpables a las vacunas
sin tener fundamento científico que lo
respalde y las personas que visualizan
la situación por los medios les parecen
tan impactantes las historias que
inmediatamente lo creen sin siquiera
conocer el contexto o la credibilidad de
estas afirmaciones
por otro lado estos movimientos se
encuentran muy presentes en redes
sociales y el problema es tan grave que
por el hecho de que los apoyó la
celebridad a las personas piensen que es
correcto cuando en realidad tampoco
presentan argumentos sonidos
sucedió en 2015 con el actor jim kerr y
que seguramente conocemos por su
película la máscara
y publicó un tweet que dice lo siguiente
california aprueba envenenar a más niños
de mercurio y aluminio a través de
vacunas obligatorias este racismo
corporativo debe ser detenido
claramente esto causó mucha polémica en
redes sociales y desafortunadamente eran
muchas malas personales que apoyaba su
postura que las que no pero en primer
lugar de acuerdo con el departamento de
ciencia y sociedad de la universidad de
madrid o el aluminio lo consumimos todos
los días porque se encuentra presente en
la mayoría de los alimentos inclusive se
encuentra más expuesto en la leche
materna que en las vacunas las cuales
sólo presentan una dosis casi
insignificante del metal
en cuanto al el mercurio este ya no se
utiliza debido a la preocupación de la
población pero ahora sí si lo tuviera
este compuesto no generarán y se elimina
rápidamente por vía intestinal
entonces yo sé que muchas veces nos
dejamos llevar por nuestros actores y
artistas favoritos en especial los
adolescentes porque pensamos son lo
máximo y tienen toda la forma pero
siempre siempre hay que ser precavidos
en cuanto a este tipo de temas
por último es necesario identificar las
consecuencias de la desinformación según
la ms una de las mayores amenazas a la
salud son los dudas sobre las vacunas de
acuerdo con la revista nation en el
doble de movimientos antivacunas que
prueba copias las narrativas de los anti
vacunas son atractivas para las personas
por crear teorías conspirativas sobre la
cura del cobismo los grupos antes la
cuna capta la atención de los pueda
conexión los anti vacunas captan la
atención de los indecisos bastante
vacunas se volvieron el centro de
atención en la red y no los probar con
esto
de esta manera ya teniendo en cuenta las
causas la preparación y las
consecuencias de esta problemática ahora
si es posible llegar a una sanción en
primer lugar si recordamos las causas
estás son creencias e intereses entre
grupos de poder si nos ponemos a pensar
en ello la verdad es que estos factores
que no se encuentran a nuestro alcance
no podemos cambiar eso persona por
persona por tanto pasaremos al punto de
propagación de la información en la que
se encuentran los movimientos
antivacunas y esta es la solución que
propongo
los jóvenes que somos nativos digitales
de corazón entonces ya que tenemos este
expertise e influencia porque lo
ocuparlos para generar un gran impacto
en redes y disminuir las tasas de
desinformación sobre las vacunas en la
sociedad
no estés del todo convencido de que esto
puede ayudar pero permíteme refrescarte
un poco la mejor seguramente recuerdas
estos grandes movimientos sociales sobre
el feminismo abusa black lo explora yo
te pregunto cómo fue que te volviste
aliado y defensor de estos movimientos
claro seguramente por información que
otras personas compartían en redes
sociales tuvo con el afán de saber de
qué se trataban todos ellos investigas
tenadas y más hasta que te comiste
completamente de sus argumentos sino
también empezaste a compartir entonces
claro que el impacto no es posible
negarlo la cuestión aquí será compartir
información que demuestre viabilidad y
credibilidad sobre las vacunas en redes
sociales con base en el trasfondo
científico el fin de difundirlo lo más
fácil
si tu pregunta es porque yo debería
participar en estos movimientos para
combatir el problema te daré dos razones
o no sería egoísta y tu parte de hacerlo
como puedes defender y promover la
diversidad e integridad de las personas
si no te preocupas por su salud es un
asunto prácticamente de vida y muerte
igual no porque tú ya tengan las vacunas
este problema llega te involucra
recuerda que no sólo se trata de ti sino
de todos
imagínate cuántas vidas podría salvar si
participas
quieres prolongar más aún estas
historias pandemias sin duda alguna
todos estamos hartos y cansados de ese
estilo de vida todos ansiamos por la
gloria de la normalidad
ya saben volver a la escuela ver a
familiares y amigos tíos fiestas o
simplemente salir ahora más que nunca se
necesita realizar este esfuerzo para
lograrlo lo más rápido posible lo
importante es asegurarnos de que la
humanidad sea consciente y se vacune
porque a pesar de que en un futuro ya no
haya cuando médico 19 el virus regresará
cuando menos sus primos
recuerden nosotros los humanos somos los
virus de este planeta las epidemias y
pandemias son los síntomas y la
desinformación este bandido